dr. Anthony Eliza woods the director of
the Yale project on climate change in
the School of Forestry and environmental
studies at Yale University you will
provide a brief overview into his recent
work at the national international
public opinions and attitudes on climate
change he is an expert on American and
international public opinion on global
warming including perceptions of climate
change risk and supports and and
opposite opposition's for climate policy
and the willingness to take individual
behavior change I'm going to quickly try
to do is describe climate literacy in
global perspectives drawing on findings
from the Gallup World poll where I'm an
advisor to the Gallup World poll so I'd
like to just quickly introduce you to
the Gallup World poll this is an annual
survey conducted in 150 plus countries
around the world representing 95% of the
world's population these are nationally
representative samples in both urban and
rural areas typically sample size of a
thousand by the way I'm on slide number
one it draws on a wide range of
questions wide range of topics and it's
translated into local languages and
checked for consistency of meaning
across all countries next slide slide
number two we've managed to get a number
of climate change related questions onto
this survey and why mean a report about
here is for in particular public
awareness and self-reported knowledge
around the world to what extent people
believe that climate change is caused by
human or natural factors how people
perceive the risks so do they see
climate change as a personal threat and
to what extent people support more
action by their own governments next
slide so the fundamental question that
I'm going to start with is how much do
you know about global warming or climate
change and people could say I know a lot
I know something or I've never heard of
it or I don't know and for the sake of
this we've basically combined people who
said I've never heard of it said I don't
know or refuse to answer the question
into one category that we're calling the
unaware of climate change and when we
calculate that out across the world we
basically find that four out of ten
people around the world
representing about 1.9 billion people
have never heard of this issue let me
say that again about four out of ten
people around the world have never heard
of this issue that doesn't mean they
haven't seen the impacts in their own
lives but they don't have climate change
or global warming as a conceptual
framework to make sense of the changes
or to understand where those changes may
be going and this is despite decades of
increasing in more reliable science this
is despite years of media reporting and
the fact that climate change is now at
the very highest level of the the
world's political agenda even despite
that we still see very large numbers of
people around the world who are unaware
of this
we've now mapped that on the map that
you should see on your screen and what
you see there are the countries in blue
are those countries where there's very
high awareness where people generally do
and know about it and in country in
countries that are colored in red and
orange by contrast or the countries
where you see very high levels of
unawareness and what you very quickly
can see here is there's a very stark
north-south divide countries in North
America Europe Australia Japan very high
levels of public awareness in central
South America Africa and South Asia very
high levels of people who are unaware of
this issue next slide please
so here we looked at some of the
countries where there's the largest
number of people who are unaware of this
issue and we divided them into these
four quadrants you see along the left or
the y-axis the percent of the population
in each of these countries that's
unaware and then along the bottom axis
or the x axis we see the millions of
people that represents in each of these
countries so looking at the lower left
we see that Mexico and Brazil are doing
reasonably well compared to most of
these others Brazil about 22% Mexico
about 36 37% are unaware about the issue
but let's now contrast that with China
lower right-hand corner
China's about the same as Mexico but
because China is such an enormous
country population wise we're talking
about over 400 million people who have
never heard of this issue within China
alone and when we look just above that
to India it
even more Stark 64 percent of Indians
have never heard of this issue and that
represents about 485 million people now
remember you know that's a huge numbers
of people that's far larger than the
entire population of say a country like
the United States several United States
in fact and these are also countries
that are now crucial players in the
negotiations both in the mitigation side
and adaptation and I'll come back to
that theme in the upper left hand corner
we see those countries where there are
particularly high percentages who have
never heard of the issue again and I'd
like to take a closer look in particular
at Bangladesh next slide please
number five this is the unaware in
Bangladesh now Bangladesh has become
kind of an international poster child
many people think of Bangladesh when
they think about the impacts of climate
change and on the left you see a picture
of an analysis produced by the
University of Dhaka which tries to
estimate what a 1.5 meter sea-level rise
might look like and that's within
scientific projections as you can see
they think that's going to impact about
18 million people submerge about 22
thousand square kilometers of land
clearly that's going to have enormous
impacts not just on those people but
those people have to go somewhere which
will have of course ripple effects
throughout the entire region as they
migrate both within country and to other
countries but it's also important to
recognize that Bangladesh is also
vulnerable in another important ways and
that's through fresh water is where the
Brahmaputra and the Ganges rivers both
glacier-fed rivers that stem in the
Himalaya and we now know that glaciers
in the hem a liar are melting away
faster than almost anywhere else in the
world
so this is the country that's clearly
quite vulnerable well how aware of this
are they on the right we've looked at
the data by region and we see that
anywhere from fifty eight to seventy
four percent of Bangladeshis have never
heard of this issue
now again vulnerability is not simply a
function of physical changes in the
environment or the human infrastructure
that's at risk it's also about what's in
people's heads and if you don't know
you're vulnerable you are more
vulnerable
because it makes it impossible for you
to start taking the protective actions
now to deal with the impacts that are
already happening and going to happen in
the future next slide please
this is slide number 6 and this is just
to represent what we see of course
around the world why are people unaware
well largely that's got a lot to do with
basic levels of education here we look
at those Bangladeshis who have only an
elementary school education or less and
we find that about 97% of those people
have never heard of this issue by
contrast those Bangladeshis who have had
a college education only about 2% of
them have never heard of the issue so
again
climate change is a crucial issue but it
cannot be separated from the larger
challenge of sustainable development
around the world knowledge and
understanding and ability to both
mitigate and adapt to climate change
cannot be separated from the broader
needs of human development including
education of people all over the world
next slide please
slide number 7 ok so we then wanted to
look all right well of the 60% of people
around the world who have heard of
climate change do they understand the
causes so this question asks temperature
rises part of global warming or climate
change do you think rising temperatures
are a result of human activities or
result of natural causes and here
fortunately we see some good results 58
percent of people around the world do
believe that it's human activities that
are primarily responsible about 25
percent say it's natural 14 percent
volunteer that it's both and only 3
percent of those who've heard of climate
change say that they don't know well
let's take a closer look however at the
distribution of those people who still
believe that is naturally caused next
slide please
slide number 8 so in this map we're
mapping where the largest numbers of
people are who but still believe that
climate change is naturally caused and
you can see here the countries in red
and in orange are the ones where there
are the highest proportions of those
people know in particular the United
States and India next slide please
slide number 9 so here we've taken the
12 major emitters what we might call the
dirty does
and we've tried to see well how does
knowledge about the causes of climate
change fall out across these countries
and ways to here in the lower-left is
that some countries like Japan are doing
quite well only about 6% of Japanese
believe that climate change is naturally
caused Malaysia Brazil Mexico Germany
all do quite well on that but as we keep
working our way up we find that Russia
the UK and of course the United States
there are still very significant
proportions of the population in the US
it's about 37 percent who believe that
climate change is natural not a human
cause problem but when we look over
across at the other two countries China
in particular is doing much better on
this interestingly than the United
States a far lower percentage of their
population believes climate change is
natural but again China is an enormous
country and that still works out to
about 230 million people who believe
that and in India again is an even
higher percentage of about 40% of the
country that believes it's natural and
that again works out to a very large
number of people of roughly 300 million
basically equivalent to the entire
population of the United States next
slide please
now we also wanted to look at how people
perceive the risk of climate change and
so this question simply asked how series
of a threat is global warming to you and
your family and again here we see that
the countries in blue think that it's
not a very serious threat to themselves
whereas the countries in red and orange
think it's a very significant threat and
we see that of course Central and South
America see it as a very significant
threat as does Africa and some of South
Asia this sense of perceived threat of
course has also played an important role
in the rich developed world the North
the global north because most people
think climate change isn't going to
impact them and thus it's a relatively
low priority for many people in the
United States Canada and Europe compared
to other pressing issues they haven't
yet seen that this is a serious problem
for them it's mostly seen as a distant
problem that will infect other people
other places other species not us next
slide please
slide number 11 again looking at the
Dementors we see a very wide range of
responses to this question in Brazil
eighty-four percent of Brazilians who
are aware of climate change and that's a
pretty high percentage in Brazil eighty
four percent of them believe it will be
it presents a very serious personal
threat Mexico also very high and India
also very high but then it starts to
drop off pretty significantly and
especially when we look at Japan the
United States the UK Germany and Russia
all chiming with what I was just
describing about many people in the rich
world seeing this as a distant problem
that won't impact them but interestingly
is the country on the very end and
that's China China despite being a
developing country and despite being one
of the countries that in fact is
particularly vulnerable to the impacts
of climate change many people in China
in fact only 7% of Chinese view climate
change has a very serious threat
suggesting that there's a lot of basic
climate change understanding that needs
to be improved within the Chinese
population at large next slide please
we then wanted to look at to what extent
people support more action by their
various governments so this question
simply asks do you think the government
is doing enough to reduce emissions of
gases or leased by Motor Vehicles and
factories or not and what we see around
the world is that about 62% a clear
majority of people around the world say
no our government needs to do more next
slide please
number 13 and when we look at that those
results across the major emitters again
we see that in almost all countries you
see a majority of people saying that
their own government is not doing enough
to reduce emissions in Mexico Russia
Japan Canada Indonesia Brazil even in
the United States and a very healthy
plurality in China all say that our
government should be taking much more
action to reduce emissions which is a
good sign for the negotiations there in
Copenhagen next slide please
so to summarize approximately 40 percent
or roughly 1.9 billion people worldwide
are unaware of climate change and that's
often the most vulnerable people this is
a crucial issue both for mitigation
reasons people are unlikely to accept
higher prices for carbon-based fuels as
an example if they don't understand why
international treaties are being
negotiated why national legislation is
being passed to help reduce carbon
emissions if they don't understand what
climate change is it makes it very
difficult for them to understand and
support those policies and it's also
critical for adaptation again as I said
before if you don't know you're
vulnerable you are more vulnerable on
the good side however of those who are
aware most understand that climate
change is in fact caused by human
activities with some notable exceptions
in the United States and India in
particular most around the world
perceive climate change as a personal
threat clearly the developing countries
see it as more of a threat than the
developed world with the notable
exception of China and most countries
want their own government to do more to
address climate change next slide please
for more information you can learn more
about this and other studies and the
following websites and I can come back
to the picture and so with that I'd
again like to thank NOAA for the
opportunity to present
I think this information clearly
evidences that there's a critical role
for the United Nations and the world as
a whole to live out what they agreed to
with article 6 of the original UN
Framework Convention on Climate Change
which is that every country that
ratified that treaty which is
international law to advance public
understanding and outreach on climate
change around the world I think it's
very clear that we still have a long way
to go on that measure and I look forward
to seeing what half is accompanying
thank you very much